welcome to GameSpot gameplay where we
show you the best games every day and
lets you make up your own mind the
general rule of thumb when it comes to
nature is don't screw with it and it
won't screw with you now I don't know
what they teach in or grammar school but
according to this clip it's not that bit
of common wisdom watch the latter half
of this gameplay for a creepy cinematic
on how nature fights back oh and there's
also a Balrog T's give us the old thumbs
up and subscribe to our channel so we
can let you know when the rest of our
shadow war coverage goes live thanks for
watching and pedometers and trees
I think if this is the world economy
this is the forest of Kannan she will
protect it with a full power of nature
[Music]
why she see him with a thousand mouths
why to be speaks not attackers they hear
a song they are part of her as she is
part of them yet they will defend
[Applause]
he is watching us cut me loose talk will
will buy our way and I found it but free
sees d'être spirit of Conan is tree and
be fine
well that wasn't there before
[Music]
Satan and unlike well if you're wrong
you're [ __ ] do you go clean without
no no my life must be starting but no
you die die cannot defeat her what would
you suggest I do throw down your sword
and
- this thing
Jaffar of the world turn on who do you
call to
[Music]
between us
here are done
Oh whoo three open it
No
I take it this is also nature
[Music]
I year to for it
more actually
wait
[Music]
it seems this caramel is healthy
[Music]
unleash to rise and rise in a hole what
have we unleashed cry of the screen
Austin rip spirit of carnage iron armor
you could in crevice Tintin I think we
hang fire together then he burned reach
fire for all it a what have we awoken on
Rainmaker you're here woken by a cost we
hear your call allow us to help you we
will find talk God
go now you're battling here are 15
shuttle fight through death and once
again you in fight soon and soon
[Music]